so let's perhaps talk about each of
these areas first deep learning that AI
how the basic question how does a person
interested in deep learning get started
in the field the Atlanta AI is working
to create courses to help people break
into AI so my machine learning course
that I taught through Stanford means one
of the most popular causes on Coursera
to this day it's probably one of the
courses sort of if I ask somebody how
did you get into machine learning or how
did you fall in love with machine
learning or will get you interested it
always goes back to rain and you rang at
some point you were employing the amount
of people you influence is Ruchika so
for that I'm sure I speak for a lot of
people say big thank you know yeah thank
you you know I was once reading a news
article I think it was tech review and
I'm gonna mess up the statistic but I
remember reading article that said um
something like one-third of all
programmers are self-taught I may have
the number one third Romney was
two-thirds but I read that article I
thought this doesn't make sense
everyone is self-taught because you
teach yourself I don't teach people and
it's no good huh oh yeah so how does one
get started in deep learning and word is
deep learning that AI fit into that
so the define specialization offered by
today is is this I think one it was
called service specialization it might
still be so it's very popular way for
people to take that specialization to
learn about everything from new networks
to how to tune in your network so what
is it confident to what is a RNA nor
sequence model or what is an attention
model and so the design specialization
um steps everyone's through those
algorithms so you deeply understand it
and can implement it and use it you know
for whatever from the very beginning so
what would you say the prerequisites for
somebody to take the deep learning
specialization in terms of maybe math or
programming background you know need to
understand basic programming since there
are Pro exercises in Python
and the map prereq is quite basic
so no calculus is needed if you know
calculus is great you get better
intuitions but deliberately try to teach
that specialization without requirement
calculus so I think high school math
would be sufficient if you know how to
Mouse by two matrices I think I think
that that deaths that desperates
so little basically in your algebra it's
great basically algebra
even very very basically the algebra and
some programming I think that people
that done the machine learning also
finds a deep learning specialization
that bit easier but is also possible to
jump into the divine specialization
directly but it'll be a little bit
harder since we tend to you know go over
faster concepts like how does gradient
descent work and what is an objective
function which which is covered most
lowly in the machine learning course
could you briefly mention some of the
key concepts in deep learning that
students should learn that you envision
them learning in the first few months in
the first year or so so if you take the
d-line specialization you learned
foundations of what is in your network
how do you build up in your network from
you know single it's just a unit stack
of layers to different activation
functions you don't have a trained in
your networks one thing I'm very proud
of in that specialization is we go
through a lot of practical know-how of
how to actually make these things work
so one of the differences between
different optimization algorithms so
what do you do the algorithm overfit so
how do you tell the algorithm is
overfitting when you collect more data
when should you not bother to collect
more data I find that some even today
unfortunately there are your engineers
that will spend six months trying to
pursue a particular direction such as
collect more data because we heard more
data is valuable but sometimes you could
run some tests and could have figured
out six months earlier therefore this
problem collecting more data isn't gonna
cut it so just don't spend seconds
collecting more data spend your time
modifying the architecture or trying
something also go through a lot of the
practical know-how also that when when
when when someone when you take the
deviant specialization you have those
skills to be very efficient in how you
build is net
so dive right in to play with the
network to train it to do the inference
on a particular data set to build an
intuition about it without without
building it up too big to where you
spend like you said six months learning
building up your big project without
building any intuition of a small small
aspect of the data that could already
tell you everything needs you know about
that date yes and also the systematic
frameworks of thinking for how to go
about building practical machine
learning maybe to make an analogy um
when we learn to code we have to learn
the syntax of some very language right
be a Python or C++ or octave or whatever
but that equally important or maybe even
more important part of coding is to
understand how to string together these
lines of code into coherent things so
you know when should you put something
in the function call and why should you
not how do you think about abstraction
so those frameworks are what makes a
programmer efficient even more than
understanding two syntax I remember when
I was an undergrad at Carnegie Mellon um
one of my friends would debug their
codes by first trying to compile it and
then it was sleepless code and then
every line in the syntax error they want
to give her the syntax errors as quickly
as possible so how do you do that well
they would delete every single line of
code with a syntax so really efficient
for general syntax errors were horrible
[ __ ] service so I think so we learned
how the debug and I think in machine
learning the way you debug a machine
learning program is very different than
the way you you know like do binary
search or whatever use a debugger I
traced through the code in traditional
software engineering so
isn't evolving discipline but I find
that the people that are really good at
debugging machine learning algorithms
are easily 10x maybe 100x faster at
getting something to work so in a basic
process the debugging is so the the bug
in this case why is in this thing
learning learning improving sort of
going into the questions of overfitting
and all those kinds of things that's
that's the logical space that the
debugging is happening in with neural
network yeah the often question is why
doesn't it work yet well can I expect it
eventually work and what are the things
I could try
change the architecture malteaser more
regularization different optimization
algorithm you know different types of
data are so to answer those questions
systematically so that you don't heading
down the so you don't spend six months
hitting down a blind alley before
someone comes and says why should you
spend six months doing this what
concepts in deep learning do you think
students struggle the most with or sort
of this is the biggest challenge for
them was to get over that hill it's it
hooks them and it inspires them and they
really get it similar to learning
mathematics I think one of the
challenges of deep learning is that
there are lot of concepts that build on
top of each other if you ask me what's
hard about mathematics I have a hard
time
pinpointing one thing is it addition
subtraction is it carry is it
multiplication law this is law stuff I
think when the challenges of learning
math and of learning certain technical
fields is that a lot of concepts and you
miss a concept then you're kind of
missing the prerequisite for something
that comes later so in the deep learning
specialization try to break down the
concepts to maximize the odds of you
know each component being understandable
so when you move on to the more advanced
thing we learn your confidence hopefully
you have enough intuitions from the
earlier sections didn't understand why
we structure confidence in a certain
certain way and then eventually why we
build you know our n ends and L STM's or
attention more than a certain way
building on top of the earlier concepts
I'm curious you you you do a lot of
teaching as well do you have a do you
have a favorite this is the hard concept
moment in your teaching
well I don't think anyone's ever turned
the interview on me I think that's a
really good question
yeah it's it's really hard to capture
the moment when they struggle I think
you put a really eloquently I do think
there's moments that are like aha
moments that really inspire people I
think for some reason reinforcement
learning especially deep reinforcement
learning is a really great way to really
inspire people and get what the use of
neural networks can do even though you
know networks really are just a part of
the deep RL framework but it's a really
nice way to the to paint the entirety of
the picture of a neural network being
able to learn from scratch knowing
nothing and explore the world and pick
up lessons I find that a lot of the aha
moments happen when you use deep RL to
teach people about neural networks which
is counterintuitive I find like a lot of
the inspired sort of fire and people's
passion people's eyes is comes from the
RL world do you find I mean first of all
learning to be a useful part of the
teaching process or not I still teach me
forceful learning and one of my Stanford
classes and my PhD thesis will endure
for some writings thank you I find it if
I'm trying to teach students the most
useful techniques for them to use today
I end up shrinking the amount of time
and talk about reinforcement learning
it's not what's working today now our
world changes so fast maybe it does be
totally different in a couple years I
think we need a couple more things for
reinforcement learning to get there if
you get there yeah one of my teams is
looking to reinforce the learning for
some robotic control tasks so I see the
applications but if you look at it as a
percentage of all of the impact of you
know the types of things we do is it's
at least today outside of you know
playing video games right in a few of
the games the the scope I said numerous
the bunch of us was standing around
saying hey what's your best example of
an actual deploy reinforcement learning
application and you know among your like
scene in machine learning researchers
right and again there are some emerging
but there are there are not that many
great examples but I think you're
absolutely right the sad thing is there
hasn't been a big application impactful
real-world application reinforcement
learning I think its biggest impact to
me has been in the toy domain in the
game domain in a small example that's
what I mean for educational purpose it
seems to be a fun thing to explore new
networks with but I think from your
perspective and I think that might be
the best perspective is if you're trying
to educate with a simple example in
order to illustrate how this can
actually be grown to scale and have a
real world impact then perhaps focusing
on the fundamentals of supervised
learning in the context of you know a
simple data set even like an eminence
data set is the right way is the right
path to take I just the amount of fun
I've seen people have with reinforcement
learning it's been great but not in the
applied impact on the real-world setting
so it's a it's a trade-off how much
impact you want to have versus how much
fun you want to have yeah that's really
cool and I feel like you know the world
actually needs also
even within machine learning I feel like
deep learning is so exciting but the AI
team shouldn't just use deep learning
I find that my team's use a portfolio of
tools and maybe that's not the exciting
thing to say but some days we use
internet some days we use a you know the
PC a the other day are sitting down with
my team looking at PC residuals trying
to figure out what's going on with PC
applied to manufacturing problem and
sometimes we use the promising graphical
models sometimes to use a knowledge
trough where some of the things that has
tremendous industry impact but the
amount of chat about knowledge drops in
academia has really thin compared to the
actual rower impact so so I think
reinforcement learning should be in that
portfolio and then it's about balancing
how much we teach all of these things
and the world the world should have
diverse skills if he said if you know
everyone just learn one one narrow thing
yeah the diverse skill help you discover
the right tool for the job so if we
could return to maybe talk quickly about
the specifics of deep learning that AI
the deep learning specialization perhaps
how long does it take to complete the
course would you say the official length
of the divine specialization is I think
16 weeks so about 4 months but is go at
your own pace so if you subscribe to the
divine specialization there are people
that finish that in less than a month by
working more intensely and study more
intensely so it really depends on on the
individual who created the divine
specialization we wanted to make it very
accessible and very affordable and with
you know Coursera and even higher
education mission one of the things
that's really important to me is that if
there's someone for whom paying anything
is a is a financial hardship then just
apply for financial aid and get it for
free if you were to recommend a daily
schedule for people in learning whether
it's through the deep learning that a a
specialization or just learning in the
world of deep learning what would you
recommend how do they go about day 2
days or a specific advice about learning
about their journey in the world of deep
learning machine learning I think I'm
getting the habit of learning is key and
that means regularity so for example we
send out our weekly newsletter the batch
every Wednesday so people know it's
coming Wednesday you can spend a little
time on Wednesday catching up on the
latest news through the batch on the on
on on Wednesday and for myself I've
picked up a habit of spending some time
every Saturday and every Sunday reading
or studying and so I don't wake up on a
Saturday and have to make a decision do
I feel like reading or studying today or
not it's just it's just what I do and
the fact is a habit makes it easier so I
think if someone can get in that habit
it's like you know just like we brush
our teeth every morning I don't think
about it if I thought about this a
little bit annoying to have to spend two
minutes doing that but it's a habit that
it takes no cognitive loads but there's
be so much harder if we have to make a
decision every morning so and actually
that's the reason why we're the same
thing every day as well it's just one
less decision I just get out in there
where I'm sure so if I think you can get
that habit that consistency of steady
then that she feels easier so yeah it's
kind of amazing
in my own life like I play guitar every
day for life forced myself to at least
for five minutes play guitar it's it's a
ridiculously short period of time but
because I've gotten into that habit it's
incredible what you can accomplish in a
period of a year or two years you could
become you know exceptionally good at
certain aspects of a thing by just doing
it everyday for a very short period of
time it's kind of a miracle that that is
how it works
it's adds up over time yeah and I think
is often not about the births of
sustained efforts and the all-nighters
because you can only do that in a
limited number of times it's the
sustained effort over a long time I
think you know reading two research
papers there's a nice thing to do but
the power is not reading two research
papers this meeting through research
papers a week for a year then you've
read a hundred papers
and you actually learn a lot we read a
hundred papers so regularity and making
learning a habit give do you have
general other study tips for
particularly deep learning that people
should in in their process of learning
is there some kind of recommendations or
tips you have as they learn one thing I
still do when I'm trying to study
something really deeply is take
handwritten notes
it varies I know there are a lot of
people that take the deep learning
courses during a commutes or something
where may be more awkward to take notes
so I know it's may not work for everyone
but when I'm taking courses on Coursera
you know and that still takes someone
every now and then the most recent I
took was a was a course on clinical
trials because interest about that I
call up my little moleskin notebook and
I was sitting at my desk is just taking
down notes so what the instructor was
saying and that act we know that that
act of taking notes preferably
handwritten notes increases retention so
as you're sort of watching the video
just kind of pausing maybe and then
taking the basic insights down on paper
yeah so I should have been a few studies
if you know search online you find some
of these studies that
taking handwritten notes because
handwriting is slower as we're saying
just now it causes you to recode the
knowledge in your own words more and
that process of recoding promotes
long-term attention this is as opposed
to typing which is fine again typing is
better than nothing
or in taking a class and not the canals
is better than nothing any cause law but
comparing handwritten notes and typing
you can usually type faster for a lot of
people you can hand write notes and so
when people type they're more likely to
transcribe verbatim what they heard and
that reduces the amount of recoding and
that actually results in less long-term
retention I don't know what the
psychological effect there is but so
true there's something fundamentally
different about writing hand handwriting
I wonder what that is I wonder if it is
as simple as just the time it takes to
write is slower yeah and and and because
because you can't write as many words
you have to take whatever they said and
summarize it into fewer words and that
summarization process requires deeper
processing of the meaning which then
results in better attention that's
fascinating oh and then I spent I think
yeah because the Coursera spent so much
time studying in pedagogy is that human
passions I really love learning how to
more efficiently help others learn yeah
one of the things I do both in creating
videos or when we write the batch is I
try to think is one minute spent of us
going to be a more efficient learning
experience than one minute spent
anywhere else and we really try to you
know make a time efficient for the
learning it's good to know everyone's
busy so when when we're editing them I
often tell my teams everywhere it needs
to fight for his life and if can delete
awareness easily to then not wait let's
not waste than during this time wow
that's so it's so amazing that you think
that way because there is millions of
people that are impacted by your
teaching and sort of that one minute
spent has a ripple effect right through
years of time which is just fascinating
talk about how does one make a career
out of an interest in deep learning give
advice for people we just talked about
sort of the beginning early steps but if
you want to make it at entire life's
journey or at least a journey of a
decade or two
how did it how do you do it so most
important thing is to get started right
and ever I think in the early parts of a
career coursework like the deviant
specialization or it's a very efficient
way to master this material so because
you know instructors be it me or someone
else or you know Laurence Moroney
teaches on tensor field specialization
and other things were working on spend
effort to try to make a time efficient
for you to learn new concepts so
coursework is actually a very efficient
way for people that learn concepts and
the becoming parts of break into new
fields in fact one thing I see at
Stanford some of my PhD students want to
jump in the research right away and
actually tend to say look when you first
come for us the peer student spend time
taking courses because it lays the
foundation it's fine if you're less
productive in your first couple of years
you'd be better off in the long term um
beyond a certain point there's materials
that doesn't exist in courses because
it's too cutting edge the courses we
created yeah there's some practical
experience that we're not yet that good
as teaching in a in a course the thing
after exhausting the efficient course
were then most people need to go on to
either ideally work on projects and then
maybe also continue their learning by
reading blog polls and research papers
and things like that um doing practice
is really important and again I think is
important to start spawns just do
something today you read about deep
learning if you say all these people
doing such exciting things what about
not building a neural network they
change the world and what's the point
well the point is sometimes building
that time in your network you know be it
m-miss or upgrade to a fashion em this
to whatever doing your own fun hobby
project that's how you gain the skills
to let you do bigger and bigger projects
I find this to be true at the individual
level and also at the organizational
level for a company to become clear that
machine learning sometimes the right
thing to do is not tackle the giant
project is instead to do the small
project that lets the organization learn
and then build up from there but just
true both for individuals and
and for and for companies to taking the
first step and then taking small steps
is the key should students pursue a PhD
do you think you can do so much that's
the one of the fascinating things in
machine learning you can have so much
impact without ever getting a PhD so
what are your thoughts should people go
to grad school should people get a PhD I
think that there are multiple good
options of which doing a PhD could be
one of them I think that if someone's
admitted to a top ph.d program you know
that MIT Stanford
top schools I think that's a very good
experience or someone gets a job at a
top organization at the top of AI team I
think that's also very good experience
there are some things you still need a
PhD to do if someone's aspiration is to
be a professor here at the top academic
University you just need a piece you do
that but if it goes to you know start a
completely build a company to create
technical work I think a PhD is a good
experience but I would look at the
different options available to someone
you know where the places where you can
get a job where the place isn't getting
a ph.d program and kind of weigh the
pros and cons of those so just to linger
on that for a little bit longer what
final dreams and goals do you think
people should have so the what options
for they explore so you can work in
industry so for a large company like
Google Facebook buy do all these large
companies already have huge teams of
machine learning engineers you can also
do with an industry sort of more
research groups that kind of like Google
research Google brain then you can also
do like we say the professor neck as in
academia and what else oh you can still
build your own company you can do a
start-up is there anything that stands
out between those options or are they
all beautiful different journeys that
people should consider I think the thing
that affects your experience more is
less are you in discomfort versus that
company your academia versus industry I
think the thing that affects to
experience Moses who are the people
you're interacting with you know in a
daily basis so even if you look at some
of the large companies the experience of
individuals and
and he was very different and what
matters most is not the logo above the
door when you walk into the giant
building every day what matters and
Moses who are the 10 people who are the
30 people you interact with every day so
I should tend to advise people if you
get a job from from a company also who
is your manager who are your peers who
actually talk to you we're all social
creatures we tend to you know become
more like the people around us and if
you're working with great people you
will learn faster or if you get admitted
if you get a job and a great company or
a great university maybe the logo you
walking know is great but you're
actually stuck on some team doing really
worth it doesn't excite you and then
that's actually really bad experience so
this is true both for universities and
for large companies for small companies
you can kind of figure out who you work
quite quickly and I tend to advise
people if a company refuses to tell you
who you work with sometimes say Oh join
us the rotation system will figure out I
think that that that's a worrying answer
because it because it means you may not
get sense to you mean not actually get
to team with with great peers and great
people to work with
it's actually really profound advice
that we kind of sometimes sweep we don't
consider to rigorously or carefully the
people around you are really often this
especially when you accomplish great
things
it seems the great things are
accomplished because of the people
around you so that that's a it's not
about the the worry whether you learn
this thing or that thing or like you
said the logo that hangs up top it's the
people that's a fascinating and it's
such a hard search process of finding
just like finding the right friends and
somebody to get married with and that
kind of thing it's a very hard search
process of people search problem yeah
but I think when someone interviews you
know at a university or the research lab
at a large corporation it's good to
insist on just asking who are the people
who is my manager
and if you refuse to tell me I'm gonna
think well maybe that's because you
don't have a good answer it may not be
someone I like and if you don't
particularly connect if something feels
off for the people then don't
- you know that's a really important
signal to consider yeah and actually I
am in my standard cause cs2 30s was an
ACN talk I think I gave like a hour long
talk on career advice including on the
job search process and then some of
these cells of yours if you can find
those videos on the oscillator pointers
I'll point people to them beautiful
you